Để chào các tí theo nó không về chính chính, mũ ba trong sâu năm thì bạn không phải không bà.
Ý tên nè, nè, nè, nè, nè, nè, kia, thuật lối điểm tí.
Tùa một tí ở kênh đảm đất, nè, nè, nè, nè, nè, nè, ní, nè, nế vỳ, nè.
Nó chỉ là không phải không bà, là game đã bị lệ, để đầm quá, cực kỳ, xác, bà, của đồng.
Một, phải không một mũ ba trong sâu năm thì bạn bà bệnh phải tám.
Bà bệnh phải tham. Nó lệ, một rất, dạ tàn dầu thật chỉ rất, đến gần bà cảm lần.
Nếu vô gàn, nè, nè, nè, nè, nè, nè.
Nè, nè, nè, nè, nè, nè. Nè, nè, nè, nè, nè.
Nè, nè, nè. Nè, nè, nè, nè, nè, nè.
Một phần chăm, nè. Tì sau, vá trong xói đó nóng ngà em đã phát chỉnh bệnh bật lộn.
Cái cây em thấy là mỗi tệnh tự của chúng ta ấy,
thì không phải là chúng ta đến từ ngàn bột nè.